what is up gq we are nct 127 and today
we are going undercover on the internet
are you ready
let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
were superheroes
what powers would they have
[Music]
telekinesis there we go
telekinesis
[Applause]
ask me
next question
who is the most childish in as childish
childishness inner city one to seven
i chose tale
there is a korean word called
yes
[Music]
who's your musical inspiration
these
[Music]
it's probably from my early childhood
taekwondo lessons
[Music]
which one of y'all is the funniest
[Music]
release so far
[Music]
what does the 127 in nct 107
longitude yes okay
how did you get into nct one to seven
destiny destiny
yesterday yesterday
next
wikipedia
okay the group performed at the 2019
macy's thanksgiving day parade in new
york on november 28th making them the
first korean artist to perform at the
event that is true yeah yeah yup it was
cold and we were smiling a lot so our
expressions froze
is that smiling my expression is always
like that so i don't know
it was
quite fun
in april 2020 we're chosen to become the
faces of korean cosmetic brand nature
republic
yeah
recently we filmed another photo shoot
if you guys haven't tried it
dang my skin is so beautiful right now
okay
okay the group is planning to release a
third studio album and repackage yeah
yes we are
it's called
the greatest album yet
instagram
all of you got
skin though
drop the skin care routine please
so did you learn anything interesting
thank you guys for all of your questions
and now we will be signing off
peace
okay
bye